[Musique]
nous allons vous conter l'histoire les
aventures des aventures nous allons vous
conter l'histoire des aventures
voeux de
là
quand on a mangé tous sens où on a envie
de boire
[Musique]
en tirer
depuis dans quatre ans sans besoin
d'appuis les moines ne change jamais
dépourvu de nourriture ils pourvoiront
amandine et carla ça ça a été mauvaise
[Musique]
o o
en
[Musique]
que fois gela renard est ce possible
je fut naguère votre voisin et je vous
aimais bien je suis feu renard j'ai été
sage durant ma vie aujourd'hui je suis
très passé et je me trouve dans un lieu
de délices tu donc mort et depuis qu'on
depuis deux jours
seriez vous disposé à changer vos
sentiments vers moi ma foi puisque tu es
mort je n'ai plus de jeunes
je regrette même que tu ne sois plus de
soude et bien j'en mets grande joie par
le plus sérieusement j'ai toute raison
d'être joyeux
j'ai ici tout ce que je peux désirer je
ne vois que riche campagne forêt verte
grâce brebis chèvres et ânes au autant
de poulet que je délire
d'ailleurs si vous en voulez la preuve
il doit s'en trouver un sur le bord de
cette ouverture
le lait jeté comme superflus en sortant
devant dernier festin
l'armée tu dis vrai quel paradis que
celui où l'on peut manger autant
attention mise en gras lé paradis on n'y
entre pas comme ça vous avez été violent
n'éloigne si vous vous croyez un état
désespéré les oies du paradis et si
vraiment vous êtes repentant prenez le
vaisseau qui est près de vous et alors
vous descendrez doucement si votre
remords n'est pas suffisant vous
resterez en haut je crois avoir nos
chances
[Musique]
où vas-tu ainsi renan suis-je sur la
bonne voie oui oui vous y êtes
et je vous la laisse pour vous tout seul
[Musique]